[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
I'm gonna get your update on sending
your oldest child off to college
I'm so proud of you right you're
following in my footsteps you know
you're being a parent who who gets who
succeeds you gotta love you for sure and
child out of your house
by following my simple program
what it was the program a simple
one-step program
pick a college or let your child expect
a college and then pay for it and take
them there is that the program
it's just
I don't I I thought you could tell me
yeah actually I do have something but
I'm not going to really built that up as
I would have a joke but I didn't have
one uh yeah I was like where's this joke
going if that was that was walking out
on the plank and then just jumping into
the seat I had a couple of options in my
mind but they were all so
self-deprecating that they might have
seen right well you should do that more
like it's like none of these are
actually jokes I have a non-joke uh
thing that I will share later about
having talked about you sending Lily off
a year ago actually did impact an aspect
of uh that that contributed to not the
process of sending them off but the the
past year which I'll talk about Oh I
thought it was in the process because I
have very one very specific question if
you did this is something that I did but
I'm gonna wait and see if it did I take
a walk an ugly cry at night is that the
specific question nope that's not it
it's different than that uh did I like
see a woman that was in a bush what was
it that you saw peeing no but I did have
something very exciting happen to me
last night that I had to share just
because it's so Timely
okay I was bitten by a spider
oh really a lot of times you don't know
when that happens until later like
what's this on my arm and then a
doctor's like you got bit by a spider
and apparently the ones that well I
don't want to spoil it so Shepard and I
were in the pool
which this is weird right this is very
strange and the lights in the pool well
it's your pool on the fact that we were
in our pool is not the strange part okay
the lights were off in the pool
and all of a sudden I felt a
pain in my right titty oh wow right
there on your Peck right at the part of
the the part of me that was exposed to
the surface above your swimming tank top
yeah right above that and I was like oh
crap like immediately reach down hit
something and actually grabbed something
and felt something large in my hand oh
crap what is that and then I threw it
down and I was like shut up turn the
lights on the pool
very I was panicking I'm glad I was not
being filmed oh my god
um
and then all of a sudden we look
he turns the lights on
and it's a spider and this spider is
swimming
in the pool
which that first of all is unusual can
we talk him backstroke or was it
flailing it was it seemed like it wasn't
supposed to be in the pool like it
wasn't like oh I'm here and I'm happy
you might have brought it in but it was
like off your like it was boot camp
beard it was big enough
to be like
still you know you throw like a little
spider into the water and it just kind
of just like immediately dies and I was
like this thing is like surviving it bit
me and now it's swimming what is going
on
of course was it black was it well it
was very hard to tell because the lights
were on in the pool and it was night
time so it just I couldn't tell and so
Shepard immediately he's like Dad you
need to go to the emergency room and I'm
like oh
Shepard I appreciate your concern
but we live in the age of the internet
and we are going to determine I mean
this is the beautiful thing about being
alive today could probably take a
picture of the spider and then it would
tell you what type it is yeah you go to
spider.net
you should just take it put it in there
well I think step one would have been to
net out the spider in case you needed to
like keep it for reference well that's
what Shepard said we need to take the
spider and you to the emergency room
good someone's the father and I was like
well hold on that might be it'd be the
case and so it was then it died as we
began to talk about it and direct our
attention toward it he was like I'm Audi
see that's that's a bad sign that means
it gave it gave you so much of itself
like it gave you everything it had I
think it was just I wasn't supposed to
be in the pool
I'm going to take a little Revenge
because I know this is not going to end
well and then now I'm gonna die
and at that point I was shining last
night I'm shooting a little pale my
light on top of I'm shining my light as
the spider floats in the pool
and like we're looking at it and trying
to figure out what it is and somebody's
like yeah that's a brown recluse or he
was like it's a brown widow which I
think he meant to say brown recluse
which is like the most poisonous spider
that you can have in California he's
like Dad how do you feel are you he's
like we need to go to the emergency room
right now yeah because it bit you on the
I mean it didn't bit you up next it bit
you over the what liver the lung do you
think the liver is up the liver's down
here brother
oh the liver's tall man it goes a lot
higher than you think yeah but it's more
down here it's behind the lung I think
on your right side a little bit and so I
was I wasn't panicking because I was
like I don't think
a brown recluse and a black widow and
all the spiders that are poisonous in
California they're so shy they're not
swimming they're not doing the
breaststroke in your pool and seeking
you out to bite you I'm like this is
going to be one of those like spiders
that it's not even a web spider like a a
hairy spider like a wolf spider maybe
something like that and I'm like and
they're not a problem right
so I'm not really panicking but Shepard
is really trying to get me to panic
are you looking at the bite
he's like is it swelling I'm like dude I
don't even know where it hurt pretty bad
as it happened but I can't find like a
spot or anything but he's like dead it
doesn't matter if you can't fight his
butt because the worst ones you don't
even feel them and then they get big and
then I'm like everything's gonna be okay
you gotta like cut it out you've got to
cut out all the all the the wound the
whole flesh I would yeah now here's the
thing
I'm just it's just me and Shepherd at
home because you know Locke's obviously
a college Jesse's still there with him
she flies back today
uh so I think he was also thinking that
like I'm a 13 year old the only adult is
here and he might be about to die from a
spider bite I've got to start make
moving and shaking putting together
plans yeah
um but I'm gaining confidence that this
is first of all it not I know it wasn't
a black widow and I was like it doesn't
look like a brown recluse from what I
remember but let's
actually again Shepard was like let's
get the net and take him and put him on
the thing so we did that
and then I'm like spiders in southern
California and then like Google like
automatically gives you like 20 entries
right and then we start looking through
them and I'm like okay it's not a brown
recluse it's not it's not any of the
things I should be scared of I think and
meanwhile Shepard's like Dad are you
feeling okay I'm like yes son I'm
feeling great
I'm going to shoot a web right in your
face
um
and then I get to Wolf and I know I say
that wrong wolf wolf wolf wolf wolf
spider
and I'm like that's what that's what it
is
and uh that makes sense that they're
like bigger hairier and uh you know more
Stout spiders that like thicker legs
make sense that they could like swim
around in the pool for a while
[Music]
um and it was like you have nothing to
be frightened of so some people might be
allergic to the Venom
of a wolf spider
but apparently I'm not I can't even see
where it bit me it hurt pretty bad it
was like known to have a painful bite I
was like yes sir like a bee sting
bee stings hurt and then immediately
hurt more this hurt and didn't hurt
again at all
huh so I don't there is Venom but I just
don't think he did much to me
okay
um so so you're able to give Shepard
peace of mind so he could he could sleep
he's still he's still looking at me as I
was walking up the stairs to make sure I
didn't collapse do you want to put a
baby monitor in there but I but I was
just so you know I was grateful because
what would I have done
in 19
82.
you'd have just waited it out and
nothing would have happened well did
people I think people knew more back
then because they didn't have the
internet they didn't have this knowledge
base that they could just consult so I
think there was like that's interesting
some dad somewhere in the neighborhood
who was like you don't have to know
things because you can know it
immediately when you need it like what
would happen is you would know somebody
like Mike mccarg right yeah and you
would call him on the landline hopefully
he would answer hopefully like his
you know kids wouldn't be on the phone
talking to their boyfriends or something
and you get a busy signal I'm just
trying to do it 82 here he answers and
I'm like Mike
I just got bit by a spider
and I'm I can't send you a picture
because that's not how it works I'm
going to describe it to you it's light
brown but it has stripes like a
watermelon on its big fat part oh it had
a big fat part
it got me with that I don't know what
what part does a they bite you with
their things right they don't stand yeah
yeah they're not yeah I believe so and
he would say oh it's probably a wolf
spider or it could be a uh Gray House
garden spider or something he'd have
something and you're like you got
nothing to worry about unless you're
allergic to the Venom you got to have a
friend in 82 you had to have a friend
that was like the internet or the
library now you just don't even have to
have friends that's the beautiful thing
about 2022. there also weren't
um
urgent cares
you had to actually go to an ER yeah it
wasn't that middle ground of like you
know I don't want to call this an
emergency sometimes calling an emergency
makes it an emergency I'm just going to
say I need urgent care you know it took
way too long to figure that out right
so I mean thanks for asking I'm fine
uh uh like a little peek you know what
the thing is
I got I got bit by a spider I don't
think it's ever happened oh it's
happened I mean I know I've eaten like
eight spiders or whatever in a year
according to that but I don't think I've
ever been bitten by spider and so and
known it you know what
scratch that off the list
but that's not what we're talking about
poor guy sacrificed himself oh
and it says spider sting
it's called a sting yeah
it's not the clamping of the teeth that
hurts yeah
it's the injection of the Venom
it's considered similar to a wasp sting
as well but there's no Stinger it's with
the mouth
yeah it's a Sting from the mouth well I
think we might need to re we might need
to contact the biologist about this
let's call it a bite
I think we should I guess it's using
your mouth it's a bite bro no I guess a
bite has to be the top and bottom
mandible
oh that's a good that's that's it it's
they're taking it's like like if I took
my top teeth and just dropped them into
your like a vampire shoulder it would be
stingy doesn't necessarily
bite a vampire Might Sting a vampire
stings because they're just using the
fangs unless they use their bottom teeth
what about a snake a snake's just using
the top things they're they're stinging
too
yeah what's going on here come on we we
need the Internet so where does this
journey begin
well I feel like I need to make a note
about Okay so
this required flying which that was this
is the first time I've been in close
proximity to anyone who went to college
that they couldn't drive to college like
we drove to college
your kid is was driven to college my
nieces and nephews they've all like
they're in the same state or like one
state over and so I was like
this is interesting we have to take
everything that he needs on a plane or
buy it and have it shipped there yeah
because for me with Lily it's like we it
was all five of us in a car but then
we we had a carrier on top and then we
had everything like jam-packed in it was
one of those things where it's like all
right you need to get in your seat so
that then I can put another piece of
luggage and then that's going to have to
be unpacked before you can get out I
can't imagine
I mean there's no way to take that
amount of stuff if you're flying well we
didn't we
had stuff shipped there and we also we
like packed some boxes that you should
no no no no
Jesse who was which we will get into
this detail but she was most uh invested
and you know she was the one that was
working with lock to make the decisions
about the design of his design oh yeah
she's the she interior designed his his
I almost called it hotel room which is
kind of what it feels like but it's
smaller than that
um how many roommates just one roommate
I'm getting ahead of myself because I
wanted to talk about so this the the
school is in the State of Florida that's
why we had to
fly and not drive with your favorite
state and uh let me just make a couple
observations about the people of Florida
now I know that we talk quite a bit
that's never been done before I know
that we talk quite a bit about
uh mythical beasts recognizing Us in the
wild yeah if you're I'm sorry if you're
tired of it but I'm going to do it again
because every time we go out there's a
different aspect that I'm introduced to
now that we're kind of like traveling
again and this there's two things about
the people of Florida specifically and
I'm not even going to call them mythical
beasts because that's one of the points
is that I was never I've never been so
consistently recognized by people who
actually don't know who I am right they
don't say big fan hey Rhett yeah they
might say it might be good mythical
morning if they can remember the name of
the show but mostly it's like oh what is
the thing you guys you taste the stuff
yeah so it's what I would call The
Casual fan
it's the people clicking on the food
videos that get it's the reason that the
food videos get the views is because the
Casual fan is like oh those two idiots
are tasting something again I'm gonna
click on it I don't really know I can't
really remember who they are but I I
like other things on YouTube a lot more
than you yeah very much the case and so
there's these are a couple of quotes
that I was I was uh that were said to me
one was are you still friends with the
guy with glasses that was one of the
first things are you still friends with
a guy with glasses that could be a very
dedicated mythical Beast because if you
get way too dedicated then that's the
question you start asking like why are
they mad at each other well and I
responded with and Jesse pointed out
later but this sounded a little cold I
was like yeah we're still working
together I'm still working together what
I meant was yeah we're still making our
show that you know us from yeah and
Jesse you made it sound like yeah you
weren't friends I was like well they
don't they don't even know who I am
they're not going to go be able to find
us to spread a rumor anyway well we're
still working together the other one was
uh where's your buddy
where it wasn't Where's link which I get
like where's your buddy where's your
buddy and I was like I
I don't know
I don't know right now not here yeah you
did not enlist my services to I mean to
help you move I guess I would have done
it but uh thank you for not asking one
thing this has made me think of like can
you fly with me so that you can take an
extra carry-on bag for my son like
that's how I would have been thankfully
we didn't need that one of the things
that I am thinking about though is I
would like to uh
get you on the fine I need your location
share with me because I get asked so
often where you're at and I just want to
be able to pull up a phone and be like
well there he is right there so many
people ask where you're at when they see
me that I would like to know exactly
your coordinates and then I will
screenshot it and send it to these
people okay okay so they'll know okay
because they are very curious you want
me to share my location with you so that
I can share it with randoms willy-nilly
with strangers yes okay you know what
good let's let's actually pause the
recording so I can do that now I don't
want to delay a second
here's the second Florida thing that I
don't know if you if this has ever
happened to you but
and I'm not saying this didn't happen
once this didn't happen twice this
didn't happen three times this happened
four times over the course of three days
okay
people very obviously just turning on
their video camera and filming
including from a distance no a guy on an
elevator
oh that's not at a distance no but in
like this he did this and uh what I'm
doing is I'm taking my phone I'm placing
it again over your spider bite the
spider sting
and pointing it like this are you
serious
that's so obvious like he can't look at
your phone I looked right at it
I didn't say anything because I was like
if I'm wrong I'm gonna sing why did he
put it up to his skin why didn't he act
like he was like typing I don't know man
that's what the other three people did
so he just
four people just the people of Florida
they simultaneously have no idea who I
am but also want to track your every
move and they want to film my every
action because they need what is
happening down there they need video to
figure out who you are later
I'm just like yeah yeah I'm gonna put
this I'm gonna put this his face into
Google
so I can figure out who this guy is
anyway that wouldn't say anything to him
no Jesse was like you should have said
something I was like wow I see you I see
you filming hey dudes phone on his chest
so if any random elevator footage shows
up of me on the internet uh uh just
looking at the camera awkwardly you know
where it was from Florida that is a
weird feeling man I mean
I I've never had a point blank yeah it's
not spend enough time in Florida you're
sending your freaking wild it's too late
now we've already paid the first
semester tuition can't get him out now
um
what was there a factor like it was for
Lily which turned out to be a total
non-factor of him concerned about his
association with you you being
recognized no interestingly so
um
you know when Locke first went to public
school from going from home school to
school which he did in the eighth grade
which is uh kind of I mean Lily did
ninth grade they both did this kind of
late late transition yeah lot was super
sensitive about people knowing that he
was my son and he was very much about
like establishing himself to like a
weird degree right
and he actually told me he was like Dad
because okay so another thing about the
people of Florida and this is typical of
any place outside of Los Angeles is if
you do get recognized the enthusiasm
like I I had a couple people like very
high
yeah like we were in a Dick's Sporting
Goods getting some stuff for lock and it
was like a group of teen boys
very loudly congregated and it and it
was like I again I don't really mind but
I don't like it when I'm with my family
because I this is this is Lock's time
we're moving him into college
and uh
and then Jesse was like you got to get a
hat and son you gotta you have to wear a
hat when you're when you're moving him
in tomorrow and sunglasses like you know
which is what you did
and then black was like Dad listen I
totally don't mind I really don't mind
I'm not gonna be weird about it and like
listen if if somebody's a fan
that's a benefit for me you know if we
meet somebody who's a fan I mean not you
know I want to know if somebody's a fan
because that because either I'm going to
be like are you friends with me because
you're a fan okay or somebody who works
at the university is a fan which you
know he's like I can't listen I'm not
going to do the thing I did in eighth
grade I'm gonna I'm into embracing it so
you don't have to wear a hat whatever
so I was like okay
um
but
I'm going to talk about the I'm going to
talk about the moving in process a
little bit and then I'm going to kind of
I'll come back and talk about the
emotional aspect of this and okay all
right let's start with the logistics so
interesting that you mentioned you know
packing the car because what we had to
do you know we had we had rented a car
obviously and we had rented like a the
biggest SUV that they had but when we
got to the rental car place
they did not have that and they said we
will give you a minivan and free gas
okay and that was pretty much the only
option I was presented with so I was
like okay and I was just reminded you
know you drove a minivan for many years
it's probably more capacity than an SUV
I'm just telling you man what an
invention what an invention and I yeah
and it pains me that it's like a tall
top station wagon I've got too much
pride to drive one on a regular basis
and at this point I don't need one I've
only got one kid at home now I don't
need one there was a moment in my life
when I could have used one but I just
couldn't do it and Jesse was even even
more so than me who just wouldn't she
would not do the minivan she would not
embrace the minivan mom life she just
was I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
let that
grip get hold of me but we should have
it was a fabulous era of time that has
passed you know ironically I think that
Locke and Lily they're both candidates
for a minivan like it I think that could
draw some trouble but I mean you
remember Greg had him had it I had a
minivan in college that thing was having
a minivan college is cool that was that
was a that was an ironic
totally functional party choice but they
just you know low to the ground drives
like a car capacity capacity of a truck
you can walk right into it it's like a
walk-in shower and just the all the the
you got USBC you got USB whatever the
other one is you got there's I mean you
can plug anything in just very impressed
with minivans yeah
you can be an adult sitting in the
middle seat back there and you it's like
you're at you're it's like you're at a
Star Trek console you're sitting upright
feel very ready for anything advanced
and very aerodynamic now we got a bunch
of stuff and by the time we had packed
the car to its fullness
it was Tetris in fact Jesse took a
picture I'll get her to we're going to
show it right now because she took a
picture when I had created the first
like the base layer of the tetris in the
back of the van she's like send that to
link because because I was like I'm
most of the times in my life when I'm
packing things that are like you've got
to get a bunch of stuff I'm with you and
you are so committed to it that I just
like I just hand you things and you just
do it
and then but this was a moment I was
like there can be no there could be no
wasted space here so I'm like saying
things like turn that 90 degrees I'm
actually just standing there and lock is
doing the stuff and I'm saying oh wow
that's the light and then oh and he's
like Dad this is crazy like and I was
like hey I guess I could have done this
all along I should I mean every once in
a while I gotta do Tetris no Brett again
you learn from the best I've never
watched you you've watched me no no I
just hand you the packages and move away
you felt it I've never ever actually
watched you closely yes you have man
um that's how you know but we packed the
whole you know obviously you've got the
first row in the second row and then
third row is folded down and then
everything ceiling to floor all the way
back based on stuff we had brought plus
stuff we had bought was all the way full
to the point where when you closed it
like you were like catching stuff to
make sure it doesn't fall off yeah good
work now
the process of moving in uh to college
uh where Lock's going and I don't know
if this was the case uh where Lily went
but it also is the fact that his dorm
room that he is in he's he's on the 12th
floor of a of a very large building okay
and
what they do is you know you like check
in and then you get the these little
tags and then you get into a line and
you have a specified window of time so
it was like everybody's not moving at
once you have to be there at 5 P 5 p.m
was our window
and you drive under this set of awnings
that they've set up because it's Florida
and it might rain
and you park and you open your thing and
then all these people oh wow not you a
bunch of people in certain shirts take
all your stuff and put it in these giant
bins
you just drive and park and then they
take it they go in they use the
elevators exclusively so no parents or
kids are using the elevators get your
stuff in your room so when you get to
your room they're just you see they're
they're in there or they're bringing all
the bins in there so you don't have to
lift anything heavy did you have to walk
up 12 flights to stairs and they make
everybody walk so we had to walk out 12
flights upstairs oh seriously yeah but
we didn't have anything you know we had
given it to everyone okay that's the
system well how many flights are there
like how much higher there's just
another couple of floors 14 or 15 or
something like that oh man that's that's
didn't get the penthouse a long ways I
mean that's I guess that's a decent
trade for not having a having to shuttle
anything up
yeah but it was I was very like you know
of course I'm just thinking I'm totally
dadding out about this because I'm like
how long have they had this system in
place did they start like yeah how many
years have they done this system it's
quite an efficient system I'm very
impressed
but this was the moment as we were
pulling up in the line when I began to
really feel the difference that Jesse
and I bring to this particular event now
I don't know if you remember what it was
like for us to move into college but as
I was trying to remember and tell Locke
and Jesse and Shepard
I was like I don't think my parents went
up to NC State with us no no no I'm
almost positive they didn't it was uh
uh
my papa took his truck we put everything
in the back of his truck I knew you
would remember this and uh yeah so he he
drove so he could drive his truck back
home
and so he's the one who helped moves in
and he didn't like and there were no
stairs and he didn't have any opinions
about like no we the whole point of us
going into our dorm room was to get us
and our stuff into the room and then
it's up to you guys to make it look the
way you want to organize your stuff hang
stuff up of course generational
differences first of all but also just
family Dynamics my parents were like
super loving and supportive but they
weren't involved in those kinds of
details but back in the day when Jesse
was going off to college her mom was
totally involved in making her dorm room
look like a section of a wet seal you
remember that store okay you know what I
mean like clothes hanging everywhere uh
no like faux leather pants and like big
fluffy shirts I just mean like intention
well that was what Jesse was wearing at
the time but like yeah like they put up
purple wallpaper on one whole wall
inside the dorm room yeah that's not
allowed they got away with it because
their room had not been painted along
with other rooms or something
point being did lock just know I'm gonna
let her do her thing well he in fact uh
I was just looking at Jesse's Instagram
post about him kind of going out of
college and she was saying that he's
been super sweet and actually in you
know he was like yeah I want my mom my
mom is good at this if she's gonna do
the work and she's going to be invested
in this
but also Jesse gave Locke the quiz that
she gives to prospective design clients
to find out what your style is so she
could get because this is his style
right I didn't even know that this was
happening until I look at my wife's
Instagram right but it helps explain why
she we had so much in that van
here but and I and I was in there what
about what his roommate thought about
this oh they they thought it was great
his roommate thought it was great and
also that's what he told you no and also
you know first of all this isn't
something exclusive to Jesse
you could kind of see parents are just
way more involved in kids lives and they
were when we were coming up about stuff
like this and like the parent the mom
and dad are in there and putting stuff
on the wall they're like you know so
this is not just something that's
happening but it's on one end of the
spectrum when it comes to Jesse and I'm
on the other end of the spectrum because
I'm like oh he's got like you're like
thinking about the colors of things like
I just put him in the room and hug him
and say bye right yeah
uh but the way that this translates into
your minivan is it's full of stuff and
so as we're pulling up to this thing I'm
thinking like oh man like I'm looking at
the other families there's a family in
like a hatchback and like the family
gets out of the hatchback and then just
opens the hatchback and that's all the
stuff this girl has
yeah and then I'm like oh there's a
family you have to build a new life on
our own there's a family with a pickup
truck and the bed of the truck it's it's
it's an extend cap so the bed of the
truck's not too long and this stuff's
not like pavement popping up over the
end of the thing yeah but we
have Tetris an entire minivan
and when we open the door things are
going to fall out I'm beginning to feel
shame yeah
and then I'm thinking how many boxes are
they going to give us like how many of
these big ass crates are we going to
fill up and who's going to be watching
I know this is all irrational and you
wish you had a disguise again I'm like
oh yeah and I'd already been recognized
by a few of the other as we keep snaking
through this thing there's we've got our
windows rolled down and there's families
good morning stuff like that where's
your body
and
so we get to that we get there and we
open it up and
it was almost like the guys with the big
bins had been prepped to not let you
feel shame okay because
we opened the thing and then Jesse was
like my husband feels sh she said my
husband feels Shame about how much stuff
we had and he was like oh no we've seen
more than this and then yeah he was like
how many carts what's the what's the
most number of carts that we filled up
today as he was as they were filling up
the fourth car he said I think it's like
five or six and then another guy was
being honest at four so I was like okay
so we're tied for the record for these
big ass bands
but you know just kind of going through
that
relieve a little tension
but
get getting up to the room and then
beginning the process of
you know she had a she wanted to do a
headboard
headboard that you stick to the wall I
love the fact that none of this is about
lock at all
uh oh yeah okay we'll get to that a
sticky headboard
okay well you know I mean isn't it a
bunk bed
no it's not the beds are on the ground
on each side of the thing okay and
there's no option for making them into
bunk beds okay in this particular room
would be helpful if there were because
it would be bigger because it's small
smaller than our dorm room what but I
did tell lock it was the I was like hey
it's just it's the same size as the one
I was in my freshman year
um
but just the headboard I'm going to
point out the headboard because it's
kind of indicative of
the difference in approach right first
of all lock is totally like
he wants it he's empowered Jesse didn't
it have a headboard
no it's it's just a it's just a it's
just a bed uh with a mattress it's just
a stand it's a frame basically and so
but then there's a wall that is up
against that this is I mean this is a
common thing you can put the headboard
up on the wall you can mount it on the
wall above a bed and this is like made
for like a twin bed you know which is
what you get in a dorm room but there's
a weird thing with like the way that
there's a board and then you know it's
got these sticky things on it because
it's gonna you can't put any holes in
the wall you know so you have to do it
with these sticky things but they
weren't lined up right I spent a lot of
time on this headboard
and then
eventually had to abandon the headboard
because it just wouldn't work and I'll
you know when I get into my emotional
processing I'll come back to the
headboard
um
but I think that
first of all I witnessed so many
families
uh impatiently being short with each
other or outright yelling at each other
as we would go around to the different
stores tensions are high like we went to
the Target and oh God everyone's buying
stuff and we went even didn't even go to
the closest Target we went to the second
closest Target and still they had all
descended upon it yeah and just people
just mad at each this family's falling
apart in this at this integral time and
I was like we're just another one of
these families that's mad at each other
you know and it wasn't we weren't really
being mean to each other but I was
definitely frustrated because I was like
I'm trying to deal with this um
emotionally and trying to figure out
what is it that I'm feeling which is
always a difficult thing for me and
we're and then we're like we're trying
to make his room feel this way and it
doesn't feel like a priority to me
and this Dad is yelling at his son
because the son just said something mean
to the mom you know and I just kept
witnessing these situations you know but
it also made me feel good because I was
like makes it easier to part way we're
just another
family or just another family that's
dealing with this momentous thing yeah
at least you're not in Florida oh sorry
um
so to talk a little bit about the the
processing of this
uh uh you know from Locke's perspective
he has been so
he's been simultaneously like super
excited about school
but also increasingly anxious about like
oh
I'm not going to be at home anymore and
I'm also not going to be in the same
city or the same state
or the same time zone or coast and
beginning to that's beginning to sink in
with him so a lot of his conversation
was around just like
and of course luck says exactly what
he's thinking exactly what is what he's
feeling which is a huge difference
between me at his age yeah you know uh
and him he he so he we are constantly
discussing and talking about things and
and so he's
there's some anxiety around just the
transition for him I mean he handled it
really really well and he's doing great
I've talked to him a couple of times
since you know I've gotten back and he's
really adjusting meeting people and like
beginning to like embrace the like I am
on my own but also not really you know
they're not really on their own they can
FaceTime with us at any moment and
obviously if there's something that they
need it can be arranged you know you
know um it's not as on their own as they
will feel in four years right
um
but
one of the things I've been thinking
about
first of all there's a lot of stuff
going on right now in in life right
there's just a there's a number of
things where I'm not going to go into
detail and nothing in particular is
standing out but just this is a really
busy time of year there's just there's
things that are stressful and anxiety
inducing and then there's this thing
that's happening where your son is going
off to college and much like you know
you kind of communicated last time
you want it to you're trying to make it
into something and you're trying to as
dads tend to do this too make make it
meaningful and you want to say the right
thing at the right time but you also
want to like feel
and this isn't something that I would
have done 10 15 years ago but like I
want to make sure that I'm feeling this
in the way that I should feel it and
processing it in the way that I should
process it which is more of like a
result of therapy and also understanding
that like oh you can have feelings and
you can process those feelings right
which I've gotten much better at
but I've also been anticipating the
really intense emotional reaction the
walking through the neighborhood crying
situation that happened with you yeah
and what I realized well first of all
that hasn't happened yet
but what has happened is
a series of like 10
over the past couple of months like 10
moments of emotion that will that will
be some degree of crying
it might just be like welling up a
little bit it might be weeping a little
bit okay the way I describe it is
uh you know when you're when you've
shaken up a soda and you and you're in
the bottle and you're like if I open
this all at once it's gonna go crazy but
if I just go
open it a little bit at a time by the
time I fully open it it'll be just like
oh it's just a soda and I think that
that might be what's happening
because
I've had a couple of like moments of
like really sort of like emotional
processing the first was putting
together his slideshow for his
graduation thing that you came to yeah
yeah yeah and like looking at all these
photos and like organizing them and like
picking his favorite songs and putting
in like that was probably there was an
intense moment I'm like sitting in bed
like editing and I like was crying right
so that was that was that was the
beginning of processing it the second
thing is
I wrote
them I wrote him and Shepard a song
right
um
which was you know
it was obviously it was part of the
process of like thinking about your
parenting changing and as you
deconstruct but I was really thinking
about lock especially
leaving like he's going he's here he
goes he's going off it's like you've
done what you can do
he's gonna be dealing with that for the
rest of his life whatever you did
um and then playing him the song
so like you know I waited until that was
the last song that I played I played it
for him and Shepard
and we were like played the track you
didn't play a guitar oh I could have
never played it for him I would be a
mess I wouldn't be able to make it
through it so yes I played the track and
um
and like lot was driving his car me and
him and Shepard like went out to eat or
whatever and then we played the song and
it was like
you know crying like but I mean I was
like
materials welling up and and lock as
well I didn't really look back at
Shepard I think it was emotional for all
three of us sure but there was like this
emotional moment
and then we like spend some time talking
after that
um
and then there's been and this is what
you know tying it back into to Lily's
store your story about Lily last year
I think I actually remember saying my
application
um
for it is like I want to make this your
count
with lock right because like is he's
super he's super independent he's always
gone he's always hanging out with his
friends
um
this summer he's like traveled with his
friends he's gone he's been gone you
know he so he it's not like every night
you walk in there's a lot it's like no
Lock's probably not going to be there
you know so he's he's sort of
already kind of establishes Independence
and his not being at home
but I was like I want to make the most
of the time we have and so
that was my kind of goal
and then we you know we had those two
road trips right we had the road trip
over Christmas we had the road trip over
spring break which were those were
awesome and that was actually you know
as we finished in Florida that was one
of the reasons he chose
uh the school that he chose
um and then we've just had more just
hanging out as friends time where it's
not
this is a dad and this is a son and the
dad is saying things to the son to try
to like correct him or guide him yeah
and the Sun is challenging like that's
been a lot of our relationship because
he's a Challenger
um and but this but this past year has
been more of a friendship and there's
been a couple of times we just hung out
and
just talked
and I have to hold myself back a little
bit from going into dad mode and advice
mode or right here here's a principle
that you should take with you and just
be like how do you you know let's just
connect and so there's been more of that
so more so than ever right this past
year
and then when we were you know in
Florida that we moved him in basically
and then we hung out or no this is the
night before we moved to Mim and me and
him just went out and just walked around
town for a while and just like spent a
bunch of time talking and
um
I mean about everything including how he
was feeling and everything
and there was and then in addition to
that there's just been multiple times
where I just kind of like some I'll see
something I'll look at his his room or
whatever and there'll be like just a
moment of like
emotion where the tears will start and
I'll kind of let it happen but again it
doesn't turn into an avalanche or a
waterfall
yeah it's just these moments of like I'm
living this Milestone moment
yeah and it's if if it's just an an
acknowledge it's not just about
acknowledging emotions but acknowledging
the you know the experience you know
emotions are a part of it but it's not
about like
and it's is it's about fully processing
things and they're they're a component
of it but it's not like well
when am I gonna when I'm when am I gonna
break down well but I just anticipated
that happening because I acknowledge
that's that's what I made it out to be a
lot like I've I you know I like forced
it
and then now I have this I have a
mitigated perspective on it you know on
the other side seeing Lily yeah keeps
becoming home she keeps coming home I
keep seeing her and I know and I knew
that would be now that's going to be
less the case for a lot because he's
gonna be further away right uh but we're
gonna you know I think we'll be more
connected via phone than we ever are
when we are when he's in town because I
I don't I I don't because it's the only
way to do it yeah yeah but like in that
moment in those couple of days yes just
having those times when it's an
acknowledgment of you're you're living
this Trope you're living this
Milestone moment that you'll it'll never
you'll never have it again even if even
if you know he goes somewhere else and
when Shepard goes somewhere and you know
sing with my kids like the first kid
going off to college and everything
associated with it
is is special
but the logistics of it do get in the
way sometimes oh I've got a brave Target
we're upset with each other well I have
a very specific thing that happened at
the moment of truth you know my adult
life
especially the past you know 10 years in
California in the past what five years
in therapy
you know you know the McLaughlin's like
we don't we don't make a big deal out of
anything like when people make a big
deal about something we're like
this person got a weakness or like what
what is it about this person that
they're making a big deal about this
because we don't make a big deal about
anything
does this person have a week you know uh
and like you know I was asking Shepherd
we all do Shepherd last night I was like
you I mean because me and Shepard are
just hanging out together as we wait for
Jesse to get back
and she's still trying to get that
headboard up yeah probably I don't know
where hopefully she takes a picture of
it um I'm asking him how he's processing
it and he's like do you remember when
Cole went off to college and I was like
huh
no
but I was like
but I would not be surprised if we did
not hug
just to be completely honest with you
now I would say that for a couple
reasons number one he was just going to
Chapel Hill and so he was gonna be like
45 minutes away
and so it was like uh you're just gonna
be you're gonna be up the road but he
just wasn't my family didn't make
moments of things Jesse's family makes
moments of things I remember like the
first birthday celebration I went to
for somebody I can't remember I was like
whoa you guys somebody was having a
moment I'm like you guys make a moment
of everything my family were just kind
of like we're not Jehovah's Witnesses I
mean we don't but not believe in
birthdays but you know it was our blood
transfusions you're gonna you're gonna
get your fried chicken and your cake and
I again I don't I don't want to
miscommunicate it's not that there
wasn't a love there it's just what we it
wasn't sentimental
outwardly and it was kind of like
I mean I'm not saying I know we didn't
hug but I'm just saying I wouldn't be
surprised I know that there wasn't some
moment where it was like let's hug and
let's say things to each other and and
the way that like lock and Shepard in
fact I I I filmed I started filming them
in the room as they like hugged each
other and stuff uh and then like like
said something offensive to Shepard uh
to in order to like break the attention
because he was like Dad it was stupid
that you were filming it so I was just
trying to
make it unusable yeah yeah yeah when I I
mean he just said something mean to
Shepard but it was obviously unjust
um
but
that my adult life has been figuring out
well what you know that isn't ex that
isn't who I am that's you know that's
the way that we did things but that's
not a that's not the person I married I
married somebody on the opposite end of
the Spectrum in terms of making things
into a moment and expressing themselves
and then
I have been processed I've been learning
what it is to like it's okay it isn't
that I don't have feelings I actually
have a whole lot but they come out
sideways because they're not pro they
don't they don't process in a healthy
way yeah all the time they do more and
more
um but anyway that was an interesting
thing to hear Shepard talk about asked
me that question I was like man I don't
know like we just didn't do things in
this way
but I'm a different person now right and
so
I am thinking about this moment and the
way that it worked was meaning the
goodbye the goodbye we're in his room
and this is day two day one was moving
all the stuff up and beginning to put it
in but because we moved in at 5 pm and
then he had like an event he had to go
to that night Jesse and I kind of stayed
in his room to like 9 9 30 and then we
left and then we were like we're gonna
come back tomorrow there's a few things
that we need to get
and then I'll just leave from here to go
to the airport
and so we're in his room
and it took us a while to get a couple
of things so we had like one hour in his
room and I had to get the damn headboard
up still dealing with a damn headboard
it's like this is headboard take two
like have a new idea for what I'm gonna
do and it may involve violating school
policy and putting a nail in the wall
it didn't because it didn't work
but at some point I'm looking at the
clock and I'm like okay I have 12
minutes because I've timed this of
course to be able to get to the airport
on time I have 12 minutes left in the
room based on the time it will take to
get back to the car
still have not figured the headboard out
so I was like I can't do this headboard
I don't I think it's a bad idea I'm
gonna take it down and y'all can figure
it out tomorrow because Jesse was going
to be back
the headboard had been a point of
contention or it was representative of
multiple points of contention about our
uh the way that Jesse and I were
relating in this situation and also
there's a lot of emotion and there's
like I'm trying to deal with this um
what am I thinking what am I feeling
about lock leaving
and I set the headboard down and then
I'm like okay I gotta go
I mean I gotta go meaning I gotta go and
I want us to be able to say goodbye
right yeah and so at that moment like's
like oh man
this is it
[Laughter]
and so this is it like so he does his
thing with Shepard and then me and him
hug and I say I don't know what I said
who said some things and I'm like
tearing up
and Jesse's like Jesse in that moment
Jesse is like okay I'm gonna get this
trash or she says something logistical
in that moment yeah because she's
staying because she's staying oh
and I was like
what are you doing
I was like
we
I'm leaving
yeah I'm like me and Shepard are not
coming back
yeah
and so
didn't you hear lots like this is it
and so I'm not trying to throw Jesse
under the bus you know or the headboard
or anything
um but she was coming back and it did
not it had not quite and she's
processing this on her own right it had
not hit her
because she's trying to get all this
stuff done in his room and not hit her
in the moment oh yeah this is their
moment this is the last moment that they
have together not ever but you know as
he's leaving
and so we're kind of mad at each other
but that like immediately
impacted the nature of the the the
process
but
and then of course she was like she's
I'm sorry I yeah I'm coming back I did I
was I'm just thinking about the fact
that we're going downstairs and we've
got all the stuff we need to take I was
like trust me I'm the one that would
usually do that exactly what you did I'm
just surprised that you did it
um but like lock and I you know he went
out into the hall with us and and we I
hugged him like three or four times you
know there was not like one moment which
is I guess I'll just hug you again
um
but it wasn't
it was It was kind of sort of perfectly
encapsulated just how this isn't some
you can't script this thing out in a way
that like
make it perfect and make it exactly the
memorable thing where you're gonna say
exactly the right thing at the right
time like
um he's gonna remember this forever it's
like and he's probably gonna remember
that in In This Moment
you know I snapped at Jesse because she
was trying to take some trash down the
stairs
but in a sense it's like no he won't he
won't remember that's my parents maybe I
don't think he'll remember that
um
so and then of course I ended up talking
to him like three four or four more
times people turn around and take a
picture of him walking back in that was
the thing I was going to ask about
uh no I took I took a picture of all
four of us right before he walked out
okay took a selfie of all four of us
that's good that counts and lock has a
look on his face I'll show that picture
uh but like has a look on his face like
this is it like that's that that's the
look on his face like ah but he's I mean
he's he was feeling it for sure
we ended up talking three or four times
before he even got on the plane because
I'm trying to like you know logistically
figure things out but the thing I was
thinking about
um
you know I have been thinking about
is just the
this aspect of oh man there's like
I've done I've done all I can do and
this I've kind of been at this place for
a while
you know I've just kind of observed the
way children are
and known that
it's much more about what you do than
what you say they're taking a lot more
cues from the way you act and the things
you do than the things you tell them
they're usually just kind of zoning out
when you tell them things but that
doesn't stop
that doesn't stop you from wanting to
say exactly the right thing like
if if there are three pieces of wisdom
that he could like take with him into
this freshman year what would they be I
want to make sure that I say those
things just like you know it doesn't
stop you from doing that
but I think there's just this sense of
all right he you know yes
he's still you know I still am the one
that's gonna be you know putting money
into his
pre-paid credit card thing or whatever
that you know yeah there's there's still
a connection there's still a big
connection I'm Still The One paying for
this thing
um and he is a phone call away but there
is and he's com he's communicative
that's the other thing yeah I think that
you know like he'll talk to people on
the phone right he's not averse to like
face time and stuff like that didn't you
tell me that he talks to
he's he'll talk to people he he lock
calls my dad
his father-in-law
uh his father-in-law I mean my
father-in-law Jesse's dad uh my brother
Jesse's brother-in-law he's good with
him he just he he's just like I'm just
going to call an older person
and just talk to them
and he's done that for years so yeah
he's he's well that bodes well yeah I'm
not I'm not worried about it and he's
you know he makes friends
really easily you're not gonna bother
him by calling him no you know
no I mean there's still that'll that'll
make a huge difference there's still
like text very much a connection like
haven't already built those type of
habits
yeah I think that I mean from my
experience that goes a long way if like
you know if I get it if I get a text
from Lily about nothing it's just like
oh that feels great you know it's I'm
it's not just me initiating everything
but there's I mean one specific
thing that was that felt
you kind of feel the powerlessness
um
and I think this is
do mostly
just to the fact that your kid's going
to be out of your supervision and often
college but also
the person that lock is
you know
his room was always a mess back at home
you have to tell him to clean stuff up
he's just he's like me you know what I
was at the time and Jesse's the same way
like we're not
um our house is remarkably organized for
what the nature of our personalities is
but that because that's not the tendency
and
things like lock I'm telling you this
thing about where I'm putting this
and kind of looking in your eyes and
seeing that this is not sinking in like
you're going to have a room that you're
sharing with this other guy
and you got to keep it clean and like
I'm giving you your passport
you are going to be responsible for your
passport
you know what I'm saying like a sense of
like trepidation that I hand this
document off to him and like where is
this going to end up no one will know
you know including him definitely and
there's this sense of and I I was I I
know Lily's different Lily's more she's
more buttoned up yeah than like when it
comes to those things so you probably
didn't have this like is she going to be
able to manage the space that she's
living in no she's probably gonna like
manage it for other people too but lock
all five of them as a matter of fact in
her room lock is different than this and
so you know I'm like but then there's a
sense of like you know I didn't know
I didn't know about any of this stuff I
didn't I was not organized at all you
figure it out you probably make well you
had me right you had me man and I also
lost my passport at one point I don't
had to get I don't recall too much I was
excited to decorate the room
with on the occasional poster we didn't
have enough stuff
you know what I'm saying I didn't have
enough things to really make a mess I
was definitely one that initiated all
right we're spending the next three
hours cleaning this place yeah
and also I don't remember ever changing
my sheets
yeah that's a scary thought but did you
change your sheets
well you just feel like it's not needed
yeah I wasn't a clean freaking that way
but Jesse was like I'm okay I'm giving
you two sets of sheets one that will be
on the bed and I brought my laundry home
I must have brought my sheets home the
other one while you're washing your
sheets which you should do at least once
a month is what she said you know yeah
uh preferably every two weeks
and then I'm thinking
he's not going to do that he's not going
to wash his sheets and it'll be fine
it'll be fine some sort of colony will
grow in there you'll probably get some
sort of good probiotics that go straight
through his feet skin I don't know how
it works
but there is that sense of that sense of
helplessness of like ah he's just he
can't do it for him he's just gonna
figure it out I can't hold this for him
anymore
um and you know what he'll be just fine
well I hope so I think he will again I
I'm the communication part is so huge
like he's not dropping off the edge of a
planet and trying to escape you I mean
he was confident enough to go clear
across the country uh you know what to
his own credit and to your to you and
Jesse's credit too you know it's like um
he's
he was ready to make that leap you know
he's ready so it's just a question of uh
you know that that's the big thing for
me is just knowing that he's going to
tell you what's happening you know he's
very upfront yeah and he's also
communicative and that will
that that
that's so much more important than
everything else you know I think and
this I'm speaking from experience here
you know everything that I made a huge
deal about I'm glad I did but like
people told me you know like
um you know I'd gotten the advice and
like oh I spent the whole next day after
my first daughter left for college
crying and then I just kind of
that was kind of it I was kind of over
it I was like well okay that's helpful
to hear because it was kind of true you
know even though I like pushed it so
hard like I want a fully experience this
yeah and then it's like um
you know I think about with Lincoln
he just yesterday just started his
senior year of high school so like we'll
be having this conversation but the
conversation that we have about Lincoln
would be totally different than the
conversation that I had about Lily and
also different than the conversation you
had about lock like that second that
middle child syndrome like I again I
feel won't even know if he's in college
I might not even be there
I'll definitely be there but uh
yeah it's a totally this is just a
different thing but you've you've gone
through it you've you've checked this
box and that for you just talk about you
for a second that's
you know it's it's a it's a privilege
that you got to experience it under
these circumstances that you have this
um
in intact
and rewarding relationship with Locke
that can be the can it set the
the groundwork for this experience for
you as a dad I think that you'll never
have again and you won't have it with
Shepard that is the most important thing
you know
we talked about this before
that the goal especially as you get into
the teenage years
and kids tend to get cynical
um they get harder to communicate with
they get more private
and they may even get mean you know I
think that happens with a lot of teen
kids they just kind of get mean to their
parents
um
and let me just say we've been through
those phases it's not like it's been all
smooth sailing it's I mean he was a team
he is a teenager he's been through these
these phases of a teenager and oh he's
really connecting with this parent and
not liking this parent oh yeah and
you're going back and forth you you
cleared a number of hurdles in at such a
point that yeah by the time you're
sending them off to college it's not
part of it well ultimately what I'm
saying though is
it's some point along the way we
received a very good advice that we have
been preaching to one another me and
Jesse
of maintain the relationship like above
all else
if the first priority needs to be
maintaining the relationship not getting
him to think a certain way not getting
him to do a certain thing I've tried
those things
you know I mean you want to obviously
there's principles and boundaries within
which you're you're accomplishing that
that's not coddling spoiling and just
giving in everything between like
disagreeing and destroying a
relationship you know and it's sometimes
it gets precarious and I know you're not
saying yeah yeah I'm just saying that
like you don't worship him no of course
not there there are these
moments in which
I can choose to say something or do
something or Implement something
that will be
long-term damaging to the relationship
yeah and this is not some easy thing to
navigate because right you're right it's
not this doesn't mean you don't have
standards you don't have expectations
you don't have house rules or whatever
and you don't give advice do we do all
that stuff
but not at the expense of the
relationship and you know I'm not 100
sure that we would have gotten there you
know you know this was something that
our our therapist started telling us and
I'm sure we would have gotten in or
realized it in a different way but when
we began to have some difficulties as
lot kind of got into his teenage years
and that was his the thing that that was
a mantra it was like maintain the
relationship
I'm so thankful that that became the
Mantra because this past year has been
the sort of the best stage in our
relationship
which is exactly what you want right
before you send them off
um
and like he you know not counting the
headboard thing but yeah yeah and one of
the things that he has said that he said
more and more over the past
year and it has increased in frequency
is just he'll just uh he would say
things like I'm gonna miss you guys
or you know I'm really
the things that you want to hear as a
parent like he's like you know
we haven't always agreed on everything
and I haven't always agreed with the
things that you've done but
I know it's the you the motivation has
always been love
yeah take this store that one I'm like
that is what you want to hear
as a parent
so you know and I I think I've always
thought
maybe when he's in his 30s and he's got
kids he'll come back and he'll say
the motivation was always love you know
to hear like right but to hear it now
it's like
wow so
yeah don't screw this up lock remember
who you are
you don't want your dad to have to come
on this podcast and say something about
you
you want me to do it for you I can like
say what like all the things that I'm
saying right now it's like you need to
don't forget what you're in college for
it's to study it is to become
knowledgeable
about stuff you better make good grades
how else am I supposed to know
I've got to look at your grades I have
to know
stuff like that
well we do have I do he does have an
incentive be a good boy for making good
grades I did we I did
he actually asked that
he was like if I make Straight A's will
you and then he proposed uh
a prize a prize
oh and I said tell him it's like I said
it's a it's a
it's a solidified future
I'm not you know I was like I'm not
above this yes I will incentivize you to
make Straight A's Straight A's I was
like hey you should have like said
something unrealistic one B maybe you
know
I think that's a little unrealistic
okay so yeah it locks off he's off he's
off he's gone got one I have one one of
course his mama's still there with him
she needs to get back she's probably on
a plane right now okay we're about to be
all right
I wonder how that went
what do you mean
Jesse getting on a plane yeah I'm sure
she's just fine I'm saying goodbye
you should have called them at the
moment that she was telling goodbye make
sure you get that track talk about the
trash
oh it's it's my turn to have a wreck I'm
trying to like come up with a wreck
that's related to like just a very
practical recommendation from fatherhood
you haven't thought about this until now
well I always like to like keep it
themed keep it themed man uh but I'm not
gonna do that
um I'm listening to
you know I love hip-hop documentaries
only if you're really into
the history of hip-hop
can I advise you to take my
recommendation but if you are
I think you'll love
um
Dilla time J dilla
um
he's if if you re if you start to get
into the world of hip-hop history then
it's really cool to know about J dilla
I'm just going to be honest
okay you know
and so here's a whole book about his
life he's a producer that uh
he was mentored by Q-tip and he started
producing tracks for them uh in their
later albums that aren't quite as
notable and then his he he I don't want
to go into all the details but like it's
jadel passed away and he was like this
uh super producer of hip-hop that was he
in in Dan charnis the author's uh
perspective
an argument he presents that he created
this whole new type of time like musical
time
which he calls Dilla time that then like
especially signature a beat signature
that is a combination of straight and
swung Time by Me by
um moving tracks independently from each
other to create a Groove so on one hand
it's like a lot of music theory and then
on the other hand it's uh
a biography of his life and it goes back
and forth and there's a lot of hip-hop
history that's kind of uh intermingled
in in both of those two
tracks that he takes so if you're like
me you're really into that you'll love
Dilla time even though I have not been a
fan of his music
um I I was unknowingly a fan of many of
his tracks from back in the day so it
was like it's a good education if you're
into it proceed with caution
don't blame me if it's not like a mild
wreck
it's a strong wreck if that's what
you're into
listen to it on Audible
okay okay okay
talk at you next week hey Rhett and Link
this is Audrey from Illinois I listen to
your guys's podcast every single day at
the Garden that I worked at and when I
was a teenager I did just sit in my bed
and watch your biscuits for an hour
straight just watch you guys and um the
longest I've stayed up is 38 hours so uh
love you guys bye what's up Rhett and
Link uh my name is will and I'm an
environmental engineering student from
Ontario I just listened to you talk
about composting and I wanted to pass on
some interesting facts so first of all
there are automated systems for removing
Plastics and other foreign objects from
compost so no one needs to dig in with
their hands number two organic ways to
count for about 40 percent of landfill
waste so there are major land use
savings from composting
on also digesters and bioreactors
capture methane and burn it for
electricity or convert it to renewable
natural gas the nutrient risk Rich
compost produced can also be sold and
the reactor conditions are super
optimized so like even bones are
composted within 60 days thanks for
talking about this love you guys hey
Rhett and Link I just listened to the
most recent podcast episode
um about sleeping and also the compost
bucket and I just wanted to let you know
that I was born in the year 2000 and I
still throw my banana peels out the
window on the side of the highway
whether that's good or bad that's what
happens
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]